So we're at the black match booth now, and it's cool. It's just like you know last year except now, it's this year
This reminds me of the beginning of team America
Can you do, the ah, "Hi Andrew Kramer here", the classic tutorial beginning?
Sure. Hey, what's up Andrew Kramer here with another very exciting tutorial.
Ha, music- music to my ears
Well, let's take the tour
You guys work with, even smaller channels that ours?
Oh yeah
One subscriber, two subscribers, three subscribers
We see sort of a tragedy in the YouTube business model
Low costs, high volume content
Pranks, beauty, vlogs
However, Corridor Digital's a great example of something that almost never happens and that
Creators are able to do something that's more narrative and story and visual based
We see sort of a lack of support in the market so we want to focus on that area where you can actually add a lot of
value because of the production and resources and everything that we do have here.
This party is kicking
Dude it's so-
Oh my God, so many people!
Three separate stages and a whole bunch of standing sets
The apartment set, standing bar set
So as you can see
three wall white site grated off.
It's like really easy to build sets and pretty much do whatever you need to film something, simply
We like the idea of cheap, efficient production six episodes in a day. Just knock it out
Green curtain around, so you can green up the entire site
Is it green the entire thing?
It's all, there's a curtain in here
Also, a giant hallway.
Yeah, this is- this door
That's our equipment cage, so we own all of our lighting inventory
Grip, electric, Distro
Pretty much anything you ever need to do a job. If we don't have it here,
We've got long-standing relationships of every rental house, so we'll get you a good price
Awesome.
Oh my God, okay, play it
Duuude
That's great. That's awesome
Hey, we got 15 seconds. Let's do it
Huh, I don't want to get arrested, help
Awkward running, awkward. Awkward like half jog run
Anyways, every single year people are
Trying to grasp for new technology, new things and new ways to do this stuff
There's 8k Cameras. 4K 60
Cameras and monitors and stuff so it's kind of like that whole game of dynamic range in digital video cameras is kind of over now
Because the good cameras exist, and they're reasonably affordable
So yeah, I think every
goddamn, lady
Why has nobody come out with like a solid focus pulling solution for Canon lenses. They're electronic lenses, right?
Why is there not, just needs a little dial that connects to the camera's lens control system, just let you pull focus
Wirelessly, why does that not exist yet. So angry.
They've canon lenses on the scarlet
So why is there not just a little dial that lets you pull winds like or pull focus on those lenses
You control it on the camera. There's literally- you can set the buttons to let you do it
Wireless monitoring what the heck's up with that guys come on. Let's get on it
Here's the thing they don't tell you about gimbals. Every time you have one, you need a second camera
For when things aren't on a gimbal because when you put a camera on a gimbal, you to balance it
And that's a pain in the butt. I will say though DJI is raw camera recorder on top of the Osmo
That's pretty cool. That's what I think the future of film making is going to go towards
So also blackmagic mini, ah, if it ever comes out, will be a great camera for all you need filmmakers out there. It looks great
The thing about this, and I'll say it on camera where we provide this specifically to our creators at no price
We are very very happy to offer when it's not being used to empower creators
Who really do believe in the value of that
But someone wants to come in and pay several thousand dollars to use the stage
We're gonna take the money so it's not just to come in and use it for free
I don't want to set the wrong expectation. That wasn't- that wasn't my expectation.
The creator space over there, too, you get an entire equipment room?
Yeah.
So it's like, there's a bunch of genie, lighting and all that kind of stuff
You know we got everything that you would probably need to do a high quality film that you're not going to get anywhere else
GG. GG everyone, we lost niko. Where is Niko? I don't know.
He's like- he just disappeared
He gets like really interested in like all the boring stuff. He was looking at those radios man. Those antennas? Yeah?
He got- he caught wind of like a 15-foot antenna that blew his mind
Wren: and since, we pulled out; Sam: we left him behind though
And I'm a little jealous, to be honest
Dude, I asked for an 8-foot antenna for Christmas, and I only got a six foot one
Oh I'm sorry
I know
I know that disappointment. You're like almost
I know it's made out of aluminum, doesn't even conduct electricity well.
Antenna newbs.
It's a decorative antenna.
Well, we got the statement of work. As soon as I click send on this email
We're good. You don't mind if we shoot a little bit. Yeah, for sure. Go for it. So you do mind
Where you say where things you're most comfortable with slash
feel like you're the most, I guess, talented at?
And where are the things that you feel like you're weakest at and want to learn?
Yes, yes, but I can do like
What 'bout that?
That's the extent of my martial arts. Thank you. No autographs, please